[Music]
hello and happy 2022.
it's still kind of weird i hope you're
all having a great time of your life
covet is still here it's going up and
down more up and down down
and
we're here to stay
and entertain you
with the sicilian series uh i was
looking a little over the comments on
the chat to see how you like the magnus
number i saw only a few people tried it
so
hopefully you'll get the chance to try
it more and let me know how you felt
about that one
i apologize for the
delay i
may or may not have dropped the mic in
my tea
sorry
and
also uh my two year anniversary is
coming up with the
with the youtube actually because i
think the first stream that i did was
two years ago around this very early
january so
yeah
i'm very glad to have been here for two
years
all right
so uh feel free to let me know what you
did for christmas and holidays and
everything
and
um
if not if you want to stick to chess we
can
talk about another favorite part of
my sicilian
experience with
um
kind of i feel like against naidor
theoretically because you know it's they
would have to um still play second move
d6
for me to get what i want but uh for
those of you who also play bishop b5
earlier or later that's cool too i means
after knight c6 you can also do bishop
b5 but i have a different preference um
so if you look back at
two weeks ago and three weeks ago that
we talked about najdorf
it was with d4 right so feel free to go
take a deeper look at those today we're
going to be talking more about bishop b5
and keep in mind i'm not sitting here
showing some super grandmaster crazy
classical game i'm showing you my
personal experience because
i feel like it's easier to
talk about
the game that you played and it's more
meaningful
than to just show some other
person's game no matter how great it is
oof somebody played duboven
got some whooping huh
yeah sorry that that that um
she's a very great chess player so
i can't can't i don't feel too much too
bad about that
um
so thinking about this position all
right so let's talk about
there are
two different main ideas i don't really
consider knight c6 a huge
problem because well first of all you
can simply castle and you can continue
by like let's say castle oh i can
actually make leeches moves now
the spell is broken and then you can
just when when is the right time you can
take you can go d4 there are a bunch of
other ideas like bishop wants to you do
not have to play those if you don't want
to but they're certainly there
is this rosalina yes there's a limo
yeah
um
but it's also
i feel like with bishop b5 the main
thing is like you're not making any
final decisions about
the the deepon's
fate
so you're trying to say like hey you
want a d3 maybe one c3 maybe you want d4
maybe
so you're kind of just
postponing
your fight in the center so
that's what that's that's a great way to
go about it so first let's talk about
bishop d7 a little if i'm not mistaken
which i don't think i am in this case
i had this game played
against
not this one just yet
but i do know i played against uh yes
bibisara
a different line i'll show that to you
but uh one of the games that i will be
showing today is the uh my one and only
win against
um
bibisara because
you know she played so great in the
world rapid templates and she scored
like wait she won one gold one silver so
it's about the right time to
mention i won
the only game in place
all right um
yeah george i wish i could take it off
but new rules new policies
let go it go away i'll take the mask off
but
um all right
so let's talk about bishop d7 first i'll
i'll come back and talk about knight d7
after two so take us for sure queen
gotta take knight takes um
possible two but it kind of beats the
whole purpose of
the move order that black just played
so
a lot of the times yep what i was about
to just say
we get this moroxi pawn structure i did
a very long video like two plus hours on
my roxy
a while back too feel free to look for
that watch that if you feel more
comfortable
with that
and um
yeah so moroccan bind
this is another way of getting to it
first i'm going to show you a very
pleasant game and then we'll show you
the baby star game because that was a
little more
um kinky i guess all right so knight c6
and
the best way to go about it was d4
knight c3 is also a possibility but d4
is
what i chose take take
knight f6 let's get this out
and
now
in a lot of morocci's
g6 is desirable right
like this getting this ginormous
diagonal is better and i agree with that
g6 is more annoying for white so if
you're playing this as black
think of g6 try to gain that big
diagonal
and
so yeah
in this game my opponent with e6 i don't
think he or
i don't think my opponent was
too experienced as i had um like 300
plus
uh
on him
so
yeah
in this specific situation i knew what i
was doing uh if you remember the
traditional marxist structures you know
there's a bishop here there's still
bishop here and the light square bishop
is very constricted because you're going
to play f32 and that's another and b3s
and so your light square bishop is
not really what you
dream about at night so i'm glad that i
kind of got rid of it but it's also
without the bishop these pawns are also
kind of wobbly so we'll see how
this game i managed to get the advantage
and how easily it is to not get it
so i'm just playing normal moves
and i think in this position i realized
that i really wanted to punish my
opponent for developing the bishop the
wrong way so i went for f4
and opponent should have
considered take more seriously
in the game i went rook b8 i'm not truly
sure
why i mean
maybe a6 b5 stuff question mark but
i just continued with my plan
and
now i simply went right d1 rook against
queen feels strong enough
and
in this moment
opponent
couldn't really hold it anymore and they
decided to just take on d4 now let's
talk about b5 what do you guys think b5
good or bad
oh i see a statement about robbing banks
when
right now
which bank
whatever you want
i have trouble deciding
i like u.s bank let's keep him out of it
all right
i'm saying good bad good that's fun well
the problem with b5 i mean yeah if you
take it yes then they can take and then
they can enjoy this yeah i get that
however the thing is you don't have to
take it so you can go e5 and if they
take
hello beautiful queen can't really use
it just yet
but
because of
how much more control i have over the
center i would you know start to
question the validity of all these pins
exactly this would be more pleasant for
white so
yeah my opponent didn't play v5 they
just took took and they went queen c6 uh
taking with bishop i think might have
been more accurate falling but like
maybe um something like this i went with
rook takes and then i doubled up up here
yeah i i remember like i remember this i
was trying to decide which side which
square to put the rook and when to do g4
and i just could not
decide oh my goodness where to go
so g4 i think if it was me right now i
probably would have gone for g4
and then i got a little uncomfortable
about e5
and i'm right i mean if i was a little
uncomfortable i would probably have to
do this and they take and then i take
and oh good god it is weird
and
um this is very unstable center the only
thing that is fixed is the d-pawns but i
still have to deal with the e-pawns and
i i just didn't want to give my
opponents that chaos so i went for rook
d1 and i started to put pressure i think
that was a fine choice i don't think g4
was necessarily like super better or not
maybe
um
maybe i felt differently because this
game was when was this game 2017 so four
oh five years ago ouch
yeah i recently realized that i'm way
closer to being 24 then 23 and it
started to actually hurt a little
just just a little but
so i went there and i booked the
counseling appointment
just to talk about aging oh boy
yeah my mom had me when she was my age
i can't imagine he's crazy all right
so
chess yeah that's the one thing i can
control
so rook d1 is what i went for and i
really liked it too
and it was kind of fun because um
opponents has to do something with this
rook they got to put it somewhere and
they didn't they went b5 and that's
where i started to gain a little bit
more comfortable
options so i took
e5 is also something i considered take
take then i went to e5
they had to play either knight d7 or
knight e8s
okay maybe not my d7 because i mean
i mean still some activity
but
98 would have been the best one
definitely and the so in this game they
actually took
i took and now 98 now my rook can get
all kind of
funny
with the opponents knight e4 can get
cute
and their c1 is there there are way too
many options i chose knight e4 because i
really liked my rook stability if it was
right now probably i would have went
toward rook c1 just because it would
have um
is there a better word choice than
torture
i feel like i use that too much
yeah i would have tortured the phonet a
little bit more
so
i
just went i should have went for roxy
when i went for knight d4
and they have just kind of backed away
which i i mean if i played roxy one and
they played queen i8 yeah i i might have
understand that more but with knight e4
i do i don't fully get it because
i'm about to start going bananas on your
king so you might as well go like f5 or
f6 or something and try to combat it
but they just kind of
let me do whatever i wanted
and yep they took over here and
beautiful finally rick d7
they played f5 which is another logical
move queen g3 another logical idea queen
e2 also seems to be fine
but it doesn't sit that right with me
first of all yes i'm attacking this so
you're not going to take it because i'll
take and my rook on seventh rank will be
too too nice but if rook f7 then i would
have to move this knight again
or do a move that is related to this
knight and i really didn't want to
do that
so
i went to queen g3 to keep the pressure
exchange it off
and here i'm gonna take a moment and ask
what do you think
white should do now
because white does have a bunch of
options
is this for me today
hold on i know there is another game in
here that is from reykjavik but
no this is corsica
and the names are right
yeah this is the main one this is the
main name but i have more games and
embedded so there will be more names
so how do i feel now g5 looks healthy
does it
what if they just get the bishop out or
what if they just take it i don't i the
last thing i want is to exchange stuff
off
what
else um i mean i'm a little worried
about the black queen but it's not doing
anything just yet
i can't take
because
that will be painful
that's kind of the last thing i would
want to do so that's i do not want to do
that
however
let me go back
if only i somehow managed to mess up
with
the opponent's ideas i could do that i
see a bishop h6
in the chat but let's say bishop there's
six okay the knight is defending it so
what if they just eat this
yeah i'm not following
so i think the best way to con to think
about it
would be um
this rook is kind of being annoying so
let's just poke it if they play rook f7
wish they didn't but they should have
then i can start getting a little funny
with their pieces too they take i take
they can't really take because i'll have
that
and they can't really take because again
i'll have background ideas
so then they'll have to
what knows what maybe queen a4 maybe
they want to go quincy for and this
would actually black is holding quite
nicely
so that's what i should have done
but in the game
they just took over here
and i took that
check king moves and they made a weird
choice of taking over here i don't get
it
taking over here would have made more
sense yeah it looks kind of scary but
i'm kind of running out of pieces to
attack them with
so
yes scary but not losing this would have
um
this would have most likely held the
game
so
i'm very grateful that they did not make
this choice
and they simply just
took this other pawn and allowed my
bishop to survive and i used that
i didn't use it to the best of my
ability bishop e3 would have been the
best of my ability
i went rookie f1
and
this is still giving black some nice
counter play queen e2 queen g4 whoa
queen g4 why am i trying to get queen g4
queen h5 or just queen e3 just getting
the queen closer it would have made
that's a little harder on me
so um
yeah my idea of not having uh hanging
pieces this bishop was hanging i should
have just saved it normally but
in reality i just went trick f1
so queen d2 and here i finally started
to play much better
and i started to pick up stuff
enjoy my game
maybe eat a little block a little thank
you for that beautiful night and yeah
here the opponent just resigned cool
tactic huh they can't take it because
hehe
yeah um so
yeah it ended nice but opponents could
have easily made me
regret some of my choices
so let's scroll a huge back
okay how much back do i want to screw
just have a huge jump actually
so we were talking about knight c6 first
right and then we were talking about d4
and then just e6 so let's look at a
different move over there what if they
actually go for g6 first what would you
do now and oh my god i think i have a
cat here
know one of the beautiful um
beauties in life
living with a cat is you will find cat
hair in the most unexpected places
unexpected times for example in your
mask
it's painful right do you does anybody
else have that
um
amazing experience
i think that's one of the main drawbacks
of owning a creature
yeah i agree
hi
so yeah g6 now we can go for d4 again
that's kind of what i went for as well
and i mean yes there are so many other
ideas too you can start knight c3 you
can
actually i mean you've already kind of
committed to c4 so sooner or later
you're gonna do the d4 anyways
so tank take let's get that out
and
yeah so
this is all theory all normal normal
developments uh black is trying to right
now get knight g4 so
i chose to stop it immediately
and then i realized black is really
winking at my c4 pawn so i tried to stop
that immediately logical
and now
is it finally time to cast them or do we
need to do a clean move
hello
well i mean at this time castle is fine
i think
yeah i mean
the ideas with rook c1 also yes
i don't agree with h4 though because h4
what are you going to do with your king
after
yeah let's go for castle
and
a6 was played
this is a very classical moroxy bind
yeah the pawn structure is just
screaming mauroxy
so
um that's kind of why uh i'm the way i'm
playing has a lot to do with the pawn
structure i actually had a very funny
conversation well very enlightening
conversation not funny we don't have my
students he was asking me about his son
and like how how much should the son
know of opening and how much he know
they were playing and the son is like
six or seven and um i was trying to tell
him that yeah he should do some opening
but not memorizing it and um so i was
trying to tell the the the father that
yeah trying to kind of maybe focus on
pawn structures like if there's opening
or isolated pawn structures it'll be
good idea to know how to play with
isolated pawns against either hit pawns
and so yeah i think that's just
generally a good idea to not just to
memorize your openings but actually know
your
pawn structures
all right so
um a6 yep
and so in monopsy bind a lot of times we
want to do rusty one eventually we may
or may not want to push for f4
possibly a knight d5 sometime and keep
in mind this is a marxist without the
light square bishops so less
constriction
less constricted bishop but also less
protection for my light square pawns
all right
so what do you think is going on here
can you say that again
um what's
the question
i i didn't hear you oh i just asked what
do you think is going on here what do
you think why i should do
yeah and make sure to consider why plans
played the last move that they did
ah gordon i wish send an email to
missouri governor
question mark mask questions
can you work on getting a pawn
well that's part of the idea yeah i mean
as white you're trying to see what pawn
to push when to push and as black black
is trying to push maybe b5 black is
trying to
play
stuff in the queen side
and like black's bishop is very
sneaky so i i have my fair share of
you know getting hurt by that bishop so
in the game i just chose roxy when like
i'm just gonna not deal with any
possibilities of with the bishop getting
funny on me so i'm just gonna go to c1
which is a great move too and
opponents should have probably
considered b5 more seriously but they
just went to e6
and if i'm not mistaken this is the
bibisara game
oh there are two two different games
embedded in it wow
oh no i am mistaken this is not the baby
star game the star game was the ninth of
sixth one
yeah okay i remember that much
cool
um
yeah this is the regular game okay makes
more sense oh this is rick yeah
and
and this guy
wait isn't this the
company's
dirty
what did i play
all right
so
after e6
babysitter is a beast i agree
she was scary i remember i was playing
under 18 and when she was
like 14 she chose to play under 18 she
didn't win it or get a medal but i mean
just
the heart to play it
all right
um now after e6 i simply just started to
go knight there four ideas now the other
way to think about it is this like
knight e2 ideas but
uh or queen d3 ideas there's way too
many ideas in this position
but i kind of chose to go for
knight a4
because well
outpost
i'm a simple
simple woman i like my knight in sharp
positions
all right
so opponent took
and
i made the
weird choice of playing knight b6 first
now i don't fully regret it but i
remember in the game i was like oh god
why did i just do this
uh because it would have been so much
nicer if i just take this and then they
still have to deal with this square
and i can just simply you know my
position is just more comfortable i
could have just went for that
but i got too greedy
and i still continue to get greedy i'm
like why did i do this
don't do this this actually is a bad
move
don't be greedy knight here was fine and
after that upon actually went queen d8
because well if they simply played queen
d8 then i did not have to
then yeah i would take but then they can
do drug c6 you know they'll still get
what they wanted eventually
i would have to bring the knight back
and i can go b4
not fun
but
for some reason i don't know why
i chose to just take it now can you
actually tell me why taking is bad
yeah
i for some reason i thought this was
fine and i greatly mis-evaluated the
position
yeah i don't know why
but
to be fair i won the game so smiley face
yeah um
i still don't know why i chose what i
chose and i made their bishop the
monster so that's kind of one of the
downsides of what happens when you play
kind of um
unfortunate yeah i think the the good
language is unfortunate
when you play unfortunate like that your
opponents bishop can get a monster and
doesn't matter how nice of a pawn
structure you have you are still going
to have a lot a lot and a lot of
problems
in
your
game so i'm just going to show the next
news really quickly because it's a very
miserable position on my opponent that
to be very generous
um but this is one of those examples of
slippery dorsa it's been a few it's been
a few months since we have a segment of
slippery dorsa because
well guess what
opponent had advantage but they could
not convert it
so here for example bishop six bishop v3
was the better choice because
now yes this bishop was in a very
beautiful day you know however this
bishop would be way more useful in this
diagonal so making those little
decisions is why or i guess not making
those little decisions is kind of why
opponent's position got a little
uncomfortable
so
he went bishop e5
and
i remember i was thinking okay when to
when do i get to play c5 do i need b4
and i kind of had to play c5 now and
give up the pawn and
i i remember i saw this
but i made the decision that this is too
uncomfortable it's too one-sided
if i'm lucky i'm gonna get a draw but i
have no um no real ways of getting
tricky
so i could not get really slippery so i
chose against before i went queen d2 i
was trying to play b4 they stopped me
and then i went for f4
trying to push a little
they have very clear ways of
wanting to punish me for my
really
crappy game
and so yeah i'm still trying to kick and
fight okay i'm gonna go a little faster
in the next few moves
because the main thing i'm trying to do
is
develop all i'm trying to do is get the
pieces a little more comfortable and
make my opponent question their choices
so um and i feel like i did a great job
because i'm making them question what
they're trying to do for example knight
f6 would have been a better choice but
they went knight g7
so they made a slight inaccuracy and
finally finally i made a great move oh
finally the idea of a directory five is
simple you have one rook
and
your rook is very active i want to get
rid of it so that way after we exchange
it off
like that
then i might actually be able to use
this open file maybe i'll be able to use
these pawns that'll at least give me
some ideas i don't have to sit there and
just wait for you to do whatever you
want
so
uh queen c2 was played yay
and again
a lot of the ideas in that the engine
presented and presents
is about exchanging the queens off but i
don't agree with that i feel like if i
exchange the coins off then there goes
any hopes of advantage i would ever have
if i want to be tricky at any point i
cannot exchange this off
also yeah fiance is kind of fun so i
went for a4
and see like again they probably should
have tried to open up a little more that
way but they didn't and i'm slowly
slowly trying to build up
some advantage
if i were black my first choice would be
bishop b2 like i don't care if bishop b2
is not
um that great looking
i'm i'm i need to stop rook c1 roxy
won't give my opponent happiness i want
to take away opponent's happiness that's
as simple as it gets
so he went to h5
and again rook c1 was still a little too
hasty
so
i think i still should have done it
though i want jerk e1 because now i'm
trying to go for e4
and e5 and i finally got it
and now
we've been we've been avoiding the queen
exchange all game do you think queen e4
is a good idea at this moment
oh
chest bones if you're watching thank you
why am i anti-happiness oh love i love
happiness just but
me first not my opponents
i like all the happiness to myself
all right
oh jess bonzo is watching nice nice
yeah queen e4 is actually a nice idea
queen a2 is also fine to be fair but
queen e4 it was a was a good choice take
take an opponent has to move this guy
because if they take i'll be extremely
happy like thank you thank you type of
happy
oh my god this would be so cool
so then of course they didn't they just
went to bishop d8 and i started to play
a little more
active finally
uh i guess with g3 and v4 are there too
but i feel like rook c4 is just like you
had to do it
oh my god why am i doing this
did i seriously do that
i think i may have done this
i give up
why did i play that
i don't know i don't understand why they
played rook before maybe i was trying to
take or play e4 e6 okay
uh rook c8 is better even g3 i
understand more even before i understand
more rookie four i don't know maybe oh i
think i was in time trouble and i was
just trying to get the move 40th to get
the extra 30 minutes
i can i can i can understand that yeah
okay that's fine
finally b4 sir funny thing though i'm
trying to play b4 so black should
actually stop this
the black didn't so i got b4 happily
ever after for me yay finally move 40
i got the extra time and now how do you
think we should try to continue to try
to convert it to a win
i mean
borges so if we're playing together then
yeah
but
otherwise you can you can be happy
let's see
hello nikki
well i mean that's in that specific
situation yes black black could because
the pawn was also on a5 yeah let's just
get pieces activated uh kenji won't just
see it maybe that means fine but i just
didn't want to deal with the check i
really wanted to attack some pawns i was
greedy
i was young and happy
there we go finally some move
i finally am getting the king active i
don't know why can't i just let that
rook be
like that rock is just so fine can it
can i just let that rook be and just
bring the king
why am i doing this to this poor rook
anyways oh yes i wanted to play king f3
and i was worried of knight d4 well i
could have just played king h3 ugh
anyways rook d3 is still not a bad idea
the only way rook d3 would not be
comfortable is if actually opponent
plays g4 to stop me
see a lot of these ideas is simply about
like g4 on its own has no purpose except
to limit my options so it's not just me
who wants to take opponent's happiness
away so does my opponent they they're
not gonna let me play king g3 or king f3
or king h3
but they didn't they were nice they
wanted to keep me happy thank you really
thank you
amazing awesome and i finally activated
the rook for the last time
and we're gonna go a little bit more
active no more back
and this is just very comfortable i just
played d6 and i think after knight f8 i
think they just resigns very shortly
after yeah i just managed to activate
the king even more and voila
yeah like it was it was one of those
games that you're just like oh my god
what am i doing and i still regret some
of the choices
and like they were they were relatively
high rated too they were like 2180
feeder rated so you know that's that's
very respectable writing
so
thank you mr dougherty
and
yeah so um the biggest thing i can tell
you about this game was just block what
the opponent wants
every single step of the way they could
have blocked what i was trying to do
okay not every single but for a big part
of it they could have blocked what i
wanted to do and they didn't
and they just granted me all the
happiness
all right now i'm going to jump make a
kind of a huge jump to be visara's game
which was she started with knight f6
and here i obviously had prepped because
i really wanted to
beat her
and so i went for knight c3
2 and g6 everything is logical
everything is theory
uh yeah the one thing that i found kind
of weird is this early f3 when there's
no bishop on a2 and there's a queen on
d7 because they really want knight g4 so
i really have to play this e3 at f3
before i can play bishop to e3
after castle bishop v3
and yeah this early rook c8 was a little
um
new to my eye at the time so what do you
think we should do
it is mauricio bind yep
is it time to go b3 or is that too
too early
is there a way to dislodge that
bishop on
g7 maybe move the queen up behind the
bishop if your white bishop
what your pawn on c4 isn't that
queen d3 is a maybe but with queen d3
you also have to be careful because then
it can get a little uncomfortable with
the knight development i mean i mean
right behind the bishop so f2 he wants
queen d2 for bishop h6 oh
yeah
uh queen d2 nice queen d2 is one of the
possibilities in normal morocci we
usually do it but in this specific one i
don't think we can just yet you do have
to you don't have to defend this guy so
b3 you kind of have to go for it
um quindito will come up sooner or later
because not with the not necessarily
with the intention of bishop h6 but with
more control
because when your queen is on d2 you're
controlling more ideas you can try to
swing a rook under there too
so i put on top e6
i have really horrible experience with
this diagonal so i just went roxy one
she developed a castle she continued her
development
queen e7 though 27 i'm assuming it was
just for the purpose of relocating the
knight i don't fully um i don't think i
have a full grasp on it just yet on why
queen e7
but i continued with my queen d2 idea
um and here she runs rook d8 i think i
had prepped her because rick's gate rook
d8
i don't know or maybe she outperformed
me because rook c8 was definitely not a
common idea
um i just continued with my idea of
development i could have taken as well
and then bishop g5 it a little
but i think i was more comfortable
keeping the tension in the center
i think i'm i'm more comfortable with
the
idea of letting opponent decide for
themselves or that i make the decisions
for them because if i take then it's
it's already decided they just have to
take back but if i just keep it here
then there that wants to have to decide
if they want to take it or not
so i just continued the jerky one
and
now i'm doing a little bit of relocation
my idea is
usually so there are
different rook placements in marxy bind
you can try to have these two
you can try to have
these two
or you can kind of try to have these two
it's really
hard to decide
which two to choose
so
i wish you the best of luck if you're
ever there but it's usually easier to
decide based off of what opponent is
doing so if the opponent for example had
a queen on a5 then yeah i would probably
go for these two
or if they kept the rook on c8 or if
there was any indication that they were
prepping harder for b5
but because they're also kind of
switching to
more of a center than a queen side i
kind of did the same idea
for example here she played
queen f8 and i'm just like
huh
yeah i did i couldn't really connect
with what she was trying to do like
i feel like she was also waiting for me
to make decisions and that's the hardest
time hardest time when you're playing
morocco because you you don't want to
rush into pushing pawns you don't want
to rush into committing to a certain
idea but you also have to choose
something
so
i went rook d1
uh in hindsight probably i could have
played the other rook to d1 and kept
these two
to be fair i think that might have been
more accurate
but there is absolutely nothing wrong
with this rook either
so she went b5 took took
and
here i was like
i really want to eat that pawn because
having that extra pawn yes they will
play d5 as as it happened in the game
but having that extra pawn if i can
actually fight to keep that pawn
this is two connected pass pawns that's
gonna be worth way more than any other
pawn on the board so i made a decision
to be greedy
uh to be fair it was a world youth
championship and i really wanted to win
because any any any point yes you're
closer to the middle so i
really wanted to win and i did to be
fair but um
thank you yes i'm sitting over here
literally just eating ponds
yeah
eating ponds is a good diet
all right so nice i went for a night to
take the pond she went d5
and here i think i should have played e5
i still don't feel like 100 percent
comfortable with if my rook was on c1
maybe yeah but again if the rick was on
c1 the knight would be under attack
so yeah so i should i probably should
have considered this
more seriously and then knight d4 and
then like i'm trying to keep the center
steady and start pushing that guy
so i didn't i went for queen c1
she moved the knight away
again i think roxy it would have been
better
she moved the knight away and
i played queen b1
oh boy
a lot of weirdness here
i remember i spent a good chunk of time
trying to figure out what to do a4 e5
knight c3
way too many options um
the problem with e5 after knight d7 this
guy and this guy is under attack so if
you play f4 this guy will drop if you
play a4 then this guy will drop so you
you have to choose
and if we're going by i want to stay
greedy then queen b1 makes sense because
you stay greedy
hello ghost of beauty
and in the game she took
i took she played knight g4 and to be
honest it is a little scary
the opponent's position upon his pieces
have more harmony the only thing that i
was kind of lucky about was this queen
was so tucked away if this queen was
even a little bit closer to the game i
would have probably paid very dearly
so how about bishop d4 take take
yeah and after e5
i'm gonna ask you should we move this
knight or should we try to kick this guy
away
why does queen b1 make me greedy because
i was keeping i was holding on for dear
life to both the a2 pawn and the e4 pawn
why not knight e c3 wait what are we
talking about
so i played h3 uh ghost of beauty it
kind of depends on the level that you're
playing just c3 is tricky it's
interesting but it won't pay off forever
so
all right h3 that's what i went for
takitaki and they went knight c6
gotta defend the pawn right and they're
also opening up the queen so that's a
little scary
uh i think i made a pretty decent choice
here of relocating the horsey
i'm really glad i did that actually this
knight is much better looking on d5 than
an 8 than in b5
and they went for queen d6
now queen d6 i think it was too chill
um
one of the best
well actually my strongest piece is this
knight so if they could get rid of it
i think that would be a better choice
right because if i end up taking they
take and they have a pass pawn i have
connected past punch too but my pawns
are way farther out
so it would be a better idea to um
try to get rid of this knight and if i
do give check
and maybe try to keep it around then
they're still this is a nice target that
they can attack right they get a lot of
tempo out of it this is def they
definitely have compensation if not more
so
she
she went queen d6
i would also like to
do a slight bragging and mention that
she recently my opponent recently won
the world
woman blitz championship and she got
silver in the rapid
so
thank you thank you
yeah um so yeah
she's developing and i also decided to
follow her lead f5 f5 was just weird
sorry
yeah after after i start so
let me let me give you a little bit more
of why i was thinking what i was
thinking
um
we were trying to
i'm trying to
because i have extra material and i have
a very cool pawn star structure and
connected past pawns it would make a lot
of sense for me to be able to defuse
their attack and then start pushing my
pawns but they have to be way faster and
way more efficient than me because i
already ate the pawn i'm happy with what
i got but they have to um
they have to
follow up they have to show me that
the pawn that they the the sacrifice is
worth it so
uh
there's a question on what are we doing
here
well uh
sicilian was the idea we're going for
opening but i'm trying to give you a
sense of different middle games and
different weird stuff that can happen
after the opening
so
in this game she went to f5 and if i was
just purely wrong i i just got a good
position after that night they just got
the way king and
i was very happy i have very funny
horses
oh how many pawns am i up just two man
it feels more
all right and i'm just trying to
simplify and there's not much after that
i'm just eating stuff okay you know what
i may have spoke too soon
here why didn't i just call knight 34
anyways i went to knight b5 and after
some takes oh kind of funny because i
can't take there's a rook d5
kind of hurtful anyways i went to a4 and
i got the king active and
every single piece that i have is better
than what she has
so that's kind of why i ended up winning
the game
so
yeah beautiful
and
i'm still hungry
yep
yep
yeah resign come on girl resign there we
go cheers
and yeah
the my prediction was initially correct
if i could survive the attack that she
was going to bring on i could easily win
this game just simply because of these
two pawns connected pawns that
she chose to give away
here
all right i'm gonna squeeze in another
game
now instead of
oh
instead of bishop d7 let's look at
knight d7
and
we are gonna probably go a little bit
faster here
uh
i really enjoyed
the maroxy bind structure so i really
wanted to play the same idea knight f6
is a possibility bishop g5 is
interesting
but the theory on it keeps going up and
down weirdly so rook c8 is very more
common
did she cry
not that i saw
so
why is why are people interested in
seeing me make my opponents cry
all right
uh so
i'm really enjoying this maroxy bind
pawn structure and knight c3 it is
there are multiple ways black can play
at knight f6 e6
if you want g6 then you have to go
knight f6 there's bishop g4 there is
too many cool ideas
and if you take a look at the master
masters database e5 is also a fun one
my opponents played h6 now h6 was a
little
weird if i'm being totally honest
but this was an opponent that i had
played
earlier
um
like i i beat this opponents a year
before this game
and um
yeah we were playing in
world youth championship 2014.
oh my god that's like
eight years ago oh
and um i managed to meet her and she was
like one of the top seed and
then we played together next year in the
world junior championship and she really
wanted to
uh well you know get revenge so
she played um
h6
and
after that
i simply wanted to actually go for my
understanding of this position there are
a lot of things that could have happened
differently so i'm just going to give
you a quick overview
for example e5 is a very a common thing
that
anand's play i don't have to play as
white against navarro
uh
oh kevin is played as white
and it's just a lot of really great
chess players
not even e5 let's take a quick look at
maybe queen c7
i have another batch of pretty decent 24
plus players
comfortably having played it another for
example knight f6
i have a bunch of 2600s 2400s playing
different lines so what i'm trying to
tell you is that there are multiple ways
that this can be played
so
you don't need to
of course you don't need to know every
single way that it's played but you need
to have a basic understanding on how
you're trying to continue get your
pieces out
so for example let's talk about the h6
real quick
i castle she went for e5 now it's
important to know where your queen
should be in this specific pawn
structure because they get e5 you can
keep your queen
on d3 right
so
with this funny
d3i queen d3 idea you can continue with
getting bishop outs maybe queen side so
there are lots and lots of different
ways of playing this
so
here black played knight f6 and i simply
continued with my
b3
ideas
similar pawn structure right as the
other games that we just saw different
knight placements different bishop
placements but the pawn structure is
very very
similar
after queen c7
to be fair this was also slightly
prepped
for
to be able to stop b5 ideas and finally
this is what i'm trying to go for
so bishop uh
bishop e
bishop e3 was a very comfortable one for
me
and rook d1 is coming up
so
oh yeah maybe knight d5 is another idea
in the game she went b5 i don't know
what is it with my opponents just they
love b5 i'm kidding i mean it's the only
this is one of the big things black can
do in this pawn structure so b5 is
coming anyways anyway after b5 take take
and
again because it's me i love my pawns i
ate it
and
to be fair this may have been a little
um exaggerated pawn eating i could have
started the jerk d1 then went for the
bishop a3 ideas
probably i was
yeah i rushed it a little
because now i have two leak pawns if
this pawn if my b5 foam was like on a4
yeah i would have done it but in this
case the pawns get a little too weak
and i would i had to play too defensive
all right
for example
now let me ask you should we take this
or not
opponent is kind of offering somewhat of
a free pawn
they can get it back soon but
should we take it or should they let it
be
the chat kind of got out of hand in a
funny way
what did i miss
anyways yeah we do have to take it i
agree also small heads up if you have
games that you intend to
um share with us
start
start collecting them over on elite
chess so you can
play gobble gobble
actually
send it on twitch in about i want to say
10 minutes
all right so
yeah i kind of have to take it if i
don't take it then d4 can get funny and
deep and they can take it so i had to
take it this one was not really a choice
rather than a must
so
uh here
should we activate the knight
yes
yes we should
the other option is queen f5 just
because you know rook can't take the
because the other rook would be lonely
the knights would have to take i'll have
to play knight c4 anyway so i just went
for a knight c4 early anyways and after
take i went queen five
finally push a little bit of pawns
and
rook to b5
well to be fair now in this position
i really thought that i had some more
that i
signed up for
and i played queen a4 that was a big
mistake i should have played
um
just a second whoa hold on ah something
like b7
well well the queen doesn't take it
though because i don't have knight d6
ah maybe queen c8 there we go
because you just can't take it just yet
then if you take over here then i can do
b7 if you take it then i can do knight
a5 that would be a fun trick
and
if you just play queen b4 then i could
do knight day five and i can try to keep
eating a low material to be fair i'm
assuming eventually something like you
know this would have happened then
there's a pawn on a knight instead of a
rook and it's still incredibly hard to
convert this it's not winning just yet
but um
i think this would have been a better
way to play it
anyhow i just played queen a4 and
funny funny i actually ended up winning
this endgame
this is not a winning end game but the
component actually has to get the king
activated that they didn't
and they just started pushing pawns king
activity man king activity in the end
game is really important and long story
short this is just one i'm going to go
real quick because i want to give you
another game recommendation on this kind
of funny how this is nuts
you